Every generation thinks they invented
struggle and somehow every generation is
absolutely certain the other ones don't
get it. We throw around labels like
weapons. Okay, boomer snowflake.
Each one designed to dismiss rather than
understand. But here's what gets missed.
In 1970, the median home price was 2.5
times annual income. Today, nearly six
times. That's not laziness. That's
mathematics.
Boomers weren't always the
establishment. They were the hippies,
the protesters.
Millennials aren't entitled. They're the
most educated generation in history,
working jobs that didn't exist when they
started college. And Gen Z's short
attention span, they process information
faster than any generation before them.
Here's the plot twist. Gen Z and boomers
actually have more in common with each
other than either has with millennials.
Same humans, different histories, one
shared future. Labels lie.